amy
et m'y attèle des amis à qui nous
pourrions parler soit vraiment vous
ignorer si elle a des amis vous ignorez
ce qu'elle fait de ses journées vous
ignorez même son groupe sanguin je n'ai
rien à voir avec sa disparition je n'ai
rien lâché et mielleux genre de femme
qui attire des animateurs vous je vous
connais emi avait perdu beaucoup de sang
mais quelqu'un a tout nettoyé son
cadavre leur seul espoir serait pas
d'aveu le trait caractéristique d'un
sociopathe c'est son absence d'empathie
vous auriez vu cette femme pour ici
volée une arme
il ne fera qu'une bouchée je vous dirai
ce qu'il faut dire uno paty et singes
savants à sage savant qui échappe à la
peine devant
une bombe à retardement
réponds moi france ni en train de me
demander si j'ai tué ma femme cet homme
là pourrait me tuer et ma version de
l'histoire et ses propres mots cet homme
là pourrait véritablement
me tuer